>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Aurelia Schultz:
So for session two,
we're covering the U.S.
perspective and to quote one
of our esteemed panelists,
"When the protection
of moral rights is brought
up in the United States,
commentators have always
emphasized the differences
between continental Europe
and the United States."
And our second panel
is going to attempt
to explore this unique
U.S. perspective.
We're going to try
not to delve too much
into the comparative bit
that we already covered
in the first panel.
So I'll take a moment here
to introduce our panelists.
I think we're mostly in
the order that I have.
Allan Adler is General
Counsel and Vice President
for Government Affairs
at the Association
of American Publishers.
And then let's see,
Duncan is next.
Duncan Crabtree-Ireland
is Chief Operating Officer
and General Counsel
for SAG-AFTRA.
And then Mickey Osterreicher
serves as General Counsel
to the National Press
Photographers Association.
And then we have Michael Wolfe,
who is the Executive
Director of Authors Alliance.
And then Professor Yu, who is
Professor of Law and Co-Director
of the Center for Law
and Intellectual
Property at Texas A&M.
And there's more information
about their backgrounds
in your full program.
So to get started, as we've
talked about a little earlier,
the U.S. approach is
generally described including
in our program, as a patchwork
or sort of a hodgepodge
of state and federal law.
So to jump in if you could each
say a little about one or two
of these kind of patches.
And I think Allan, we
can start with you.
>> Allan Adler: Thank you.
I was very relieved to
hear Eric at the very end
of the panel issue sort of
a half lawyer's disclaimer.
I was rather surprised to
see five lawyers on a panel
and no opening disclaimer
about whether
or not they're expressing
views on behalf
of a client or an employer.
So I will do so, and the
reason for that is chiefly
because when the House
Judiciary Committee's process
on comprehensive review
of copyright law considered
the issue of moral rights,
they did so in a hearing
in which moral rights
was one subject combined
with copyright term
and termination rights,
which I think led people to look
at that hearing in two ways.
One of which it was kind of
a collective checkoff box
to make sure that even
relatively obscure issues as far
as the public was
concerned would be addressed
in the comprehensive
process of review.
But also I think it was a signal
that these three issues
together are issues
that despite any other pretense
the committee might make during
the process, are highly
unlikely to see any kind
of reform legislation as a
result of the hearing process.
And that is in part, because
I think the issue was largely
viewed as having been put
to rest during the period
that the previous panel
discussed in the late 1980s.
For the publishing
community at the time,
they had mustered a sufficient
amount of fire and brimstone
to help put that issue to
rest in terms of legislation.
I'll give you just a quick
example of the kind of language
that was used at the time,
testimony of the AAP
before the Senate said
that the hearing raises the
threshold policy question
of whether to superimpose
vague, subjective,
and wholly unpredictable new
rights upon a longstanding,
balanced, and successful
copyright system.
Tell us what you
really think publishers.
So I think that type of view of
the issue is one that led us,
at least at the AAP, when the
hearing was held two years ago
by the House Judiciary
Committee to look at the issue
of moral rights and
actually to make the decision
that we were not going to submit
a statement for the record
because we didn't have anything
new to say about the issue.
When I say nothing
new it's not to say
that we don't have anything
to say about the issue at all.
In the 1980s we said a
great deal about the issue,
particularly in terms
of concerns not only
that the United States
had bodies of law
which addressed the issues
of integrity and attribution
as they appear in 6bis, but
also because we have laws
that distinguish the
United States from the rest
of the world, primarily,
the First Amendment
in our Constitution, which
protects freedom of speech
from freedom of expression
generally.
The Congress and the Supreme
Court had no difficulty
over the years reconciling
the First Amendment
with U.S. copyright law,
notwithstanding the fact
that some view the copyright law
as basically restricting what
people can do when they choose
to use a work of original
expression as a form of speech.
But nevertheless, it has
played a very important role
in shaping the way U.S.
copyright law has in fact,
been implemented, and it's
also an important bulwark
with respect to the
issue of moral rights.
Because if you look in
this country at the issue
of defamation law,
defamation law is a creature
of both federal law
and state law.
Primarily it's a
creature of state law
but the First Amendment
makes it also to some extent,
a creature of federal
law as well.
At least when we're talking
about public figures or even
about private figures but
we're dealing with issues
of public concern and
public importance.
So in the area of U.S. laws
that were supposed to chime in
and count for representing
the principles of 6bis
on moral rights, one looked
at the issue of integrity
and noticed that they talk
about the ability to object
to any distortion, mutilation,
or other modification of,
or other derogatory action
in relation to the said work
which would be prejudicial
to the author's honor
or reputation.
The interesting thing
about that in terms
of the way U.S. defamation law
works is the defamation law is
probably both broader and
narrower in a number of senses.
For one thing, the interesting
thing about the 6bis language is
that when we're talking
about derogatory action
that would be prejudicial to the
author's honor or reputation,
we're talking about
derogatory action
in relation to the
specific work.
We're not talking just
about general statements
that would be viewed as
derogatory or defamatory
to the reputation of the author.
It has to be something
that relates to the work
that then casts the author
in what would be viewed
as a disreputable light.
That of course is not
at all true with respect
to defamatory law in
the United States.
The way the law has grown
both as a matter of common law
and in terms of state statutory
law, it's a civil wrong.
It's a tort.
It can be either written
in the form of libel
or it can be spoken, which
would make it slander.
It could even be expressed other
than by writing or
by oral comment.
It must be published
in the sense
that a third party must
have seen, heard, or read
and understood it to be about
the subject and to be damaging
to the subject's reputation.
If you read the language of
6bis, it is not at all clear
that this can't be a direct
discussion between a reviewer
for example and the
author of a work
in which the author concludes
that the reviewer's comments are
in fact, derogatory in the sense
that is contemplated under 6bis.
But most importantly
in defamation law
in the United States,
the issue of the falsity
of the facts asserted
with respect
to the subject individual
who believes that his
or her reputation has been
harmed is an absolutely
critical matter.
Even to the extent that the
First Amendment provides some
breathing room for people to
engage in commentary and speech
that might be viewed
as the subject
of that commentary
speech is derogatory
to their reputation and honor.
Unless they can point to the
falsity of what was said,
they really don't have any
kind of action with respect
to slander or libel
under U.S. law.
Whereas the notion, I think of
comparative notion to defamation
in 6bis doesn't address
the question
of whether what is said contains
an element of falsehood.
And as we know, we
see a number of areas
where people will engage
in what has been referred
to as libel tourism to
avoid bringing libel actions
that really belong in the United
States courts based upon the
subject matter, based upon
the vehicle that was used
to make the statements an issue.
But people tend to
travel to other countries,
particularly the U.K. to
file libel actions there
because of the differences
in the coverage of defamation
and what has to be proven in
order to be able to make a case.
In most areas of the United
States it's also important
that a defamatory statement be
one that isn't unprivileged.
In other words, if you
are in the situation
where you are a witness
in a trial proceeding,
whether it's civil or criminal,
your testimony is privileged
with respect to any character
of it that might be viewed
as defamatory because
it is part of a process
in which what you say
is being considered more
for its relationship to the
particular cause of action
or the particular charge
defense than it has to do
with the character of
the particular individual
that the matter dealt with.
So that's another
important element.
And of course as I
mentioned earlier,
there is this distinction
made in U.S. law
between how the law
treats a public figure
and treats a private figure.
And generally speaking
as we know
under the Sullivan
doctrine, when we're talking
about a public figure,
an individual who's an elected
official or somebody else
who has entered into the
public spotlight as far
as society is concerned,
generally speaking they have
a heavier burden of proof
with respect to an action for
defamation, whether it's libel
or slander, in having to
demonstrate actual malice.
Which is not only that the
statements involved were false,
but that the speaker either knew
they were false or spoke them
in reckless disregard
for whether
or not they were true or false.
And none of this is reflected
in the language of 6bis
with respect to the idea of
harm to reputation or honor.
And most importantly, perhaps,
in the United States generally
speaking, with respect
to defamation, an action
for defamation does not
survive the death of the subject
of that alleged defamation.
So you had a very famous
case a number of years ago
where the children of the noted
actor Errol Flynn attempted
to sue for defamation of Flynn's
character based upon a book
that was written, an
unauthorized biography of Flynn
that alleged that he
was a Nazi sympathizer.
And of course the
court basically said
that those actions
had they been brought
by Mr. Flynn during his life,
might have had some validity
but they had no validity as
far as being brought by those
who were his heirs
or even his estate.
So that's a fairly
substantial way
in which even though the
notion of defamation law
in the United States as
it exists serves as a kind
of an analog to the
integrity rights
that are protected under 6bis.
They're really quite
different in practice.
>> Aurelia Schultz:
Thank you Allan.
Duncan, Allan's covered kind
of one way that the right
of integrity and the author's
reputation can be protected.
Could you tell us a little bit
about how publicity rights
also work in this area?
>> Duncan Crabtree-Ireland:
Sure that would be great
and I'll probably mention
the Berne Convention less
than anyone in the entire day.
If you're thinking "Well I
wonder why that would be?"
In case you don't know,
SAG-AFTRA is the union
that covers performers, actors,
broadcasters, recording artists,
and so as I think was mentioned
during the esteemed academic
panel before us, largely those
individuals have been left
out of the Berne Convention,
but thankfully, there's the WPPT
for our recording artist and
there is the Beijing Treaty.
Hopefully someday
they enter into force
for our audio visual performers,
and so you won't hear a lengthy
discussion of Berne from me,
but I would like to just talk
for a minute about the right
of publicity and its importance,
particularly to performers
since that's the
perspective that I come from,
spending almost 24 hours
a day, seven days a week,
365 days a year around them.
I think for most performers,
you know, we've had a,
I think for me, a very
fascinating academic discussion
so far about how the various
elements of moral rights,
the patchwork quilt work.
For most performers, I think
they're more interested
in a functional approach
to these rights,
because what they're interested
in is really two things
as has been stated by
several other people.
Number one, the question
of how they can protect
their non-economic rights,
whatever those rights
may be and number two,
how they protect
their economic rights.
And I would say not
necessarily in that order.
Depending on the performer,
the reality of course
is making a living
as a performer is often the
number one consideration
for most performers.
It's a very difficult
career to pursue.
It is a lifestyle for most
performers where fighting
for the very, you
know, basic elements
of life can be a real challenge,
and so as representatives
of performers for those who
have not achieved a high degree
of career success,
basic elements
and typically compensation are
the number one consideration.
And so the right for
publicity as part
of a broader moral rights
patchwork is really important
and is in fact is utilized.
For those who might not
be paying attention to it,
there have been a number
of high profile cases,
litigations that have
been initiated seeking
to enforce rights under
the right of publicity.
And I guess I should just
say you know, what it is
or what form it takes at
least here in the U.S.
From some people's perspective,
regrettably it's not
really a federalized right.
This is a right that is a sort
of common law right that you see
in a number of states.
Last count I think around
28 or states have some form
of either common law
or statutory right
of publicity embodied, you
know, there's a few states known
as being very receptive to
right of publicity statutes
that have really built a strong
framework for individuals
and performers, in particular,
in my perspective, New York,
California, Indiana jump
to mind as a few of those.
But I do think that it is
more than an academic case.
There have been a number of
cases in the Ninth Circuit
for example, and in other
circuits in the U.S.
where various types of
performers have sought
to pursue economic compensation
for violations for the rights
of publicity ranging from
commercial advertising types
of cases to cases involving
particularly video games
in recent years.
There is, I think, sort of a
brand integrity element of this,
particularly that you see in
these cases that have made it
into the appellate process
where we've got compensation
on one hand where we're got a
desire to really use the right
of publicity to protect the
types of uses that are made
of image and likeness
of individuals.
And that's something that
otherwise really you have
to rely on a contractual
framework to protect outside
of that and maybe the Lanham Act
which thankfully
I'm not responsible
for talking about today.
And so I think from a
performer's perspective,
that is a really
important option.
We did see recently I mean,
I think a very interesting
litigation attempting
to pursue this type
of brand integrity
or personal rights protection
through a copyright angle
which of course is the
Google Garcia case and,
you know prompted, I think,
some very interesting writings
in the Ninth Circuit
level in particular.
So for those who haven't checked
out Judge Kozinski's opinion
in that case and the
subsequent en banc result,
you should probably do that.
But I think that, you know, from
my perspective, that's the type
of case that really never
should have been brought
in the first place,
because a better,
a lot of us were mystified
as to why the plaintiff
in that case didn't pursue a
right of publicity approach
to that issue rather than
the copyright approach
that was pursued.
And so from a practical point of
view, again a functional point
of view, that's something
that we always try to discuss
with our members and
our performers which is
to really make sure that
they have an understanding
because it is a patchwork, of
the various options for seeking
to vindicate your rights and
making sure that when you do
that you don't create
unfortunate
or counterproductive
precedence or, you know,
cause harm to an otherwise
precariously balanced system.
I think I couldn't wrap up
without talking for a minute
about the Beijing Treaty.
It's something that's very close
to the hearts of our members,
particularly our actor
performer members,
obviously our recording artists
members have enjoyed similar
protections under the
WPPT for some time.
And actually when you look at
the range of our membership,
they speak out very strongly
in favor of the Beijing Treaty,
both from with the knowledge
of the specifics of the treaty
which obviously is complex and
takes some time to understand,
but also from a more fundamental
place which is the really
in some ways shocking lack
of international recognition
of performer's rights
in the audiovisual space
for such a long time
and the joy, frankly,
that our performers have setting
aside the details as the concept
of being recognized in the way
that they haven't been so far
and even our recording artist
members have stepped up to speak
out and say it's not fair
that our actor brothers
and sisters are not protected
in the same way that we
as recording artists are
at the international level.
And so that's something
that's really important to us,
of course, the implementation;
someone mentioned earlier
that the president had sent
the treaty to the Senate
for ratification and, of course,
the implementation package
has also been made public
and there are definitely some
interesting issues that really,
I think you know, relate
to primarily the
anti-bootlegging area
which is the focus
of the implementation
package that's going
to cause some interesting
debates.
And I think there is some
disagreement about the necessity
of the scope of the
changes that are proposed
in the implementation package,
but ultimately, it is our hope
and desire that moral rights
for all you visual
performers get enshrined
in international law in
way that's meaningful both
on a detailed and functional
level, but also from sort
of the philosophical and
principle level to ensure
that we would then finally
have a broad range of rights
for all types of performers;
moral rights and economic rights
at the international level.
So I'll think I'll stop there.
Thanks.
>> Aurelia Schultz: Thank you.
And you mentioned your relief
not discussing the Lanham Act.
And Eric very helpfully
on the last panel
summarized Dastar for us.
So Professor Yu, if I could
ask you to kind of pickup
that heavy load and tell
us a bit about Lanham Act
and using statutes like that
that are not copyright law
to help protect something
like moral rights.
>> Peter K. Yu: So in terms
of unfair competition law,
we should start over Section
43(a) of the Lanham Act,
and so Eric earlier
mentioned at the Dastar case
and I suspect Professor Ginsburg
will also talk a little bit
about that as well.
And so for Section 43(a) we do,
it offers two different
types of protection.
The first one is it protects
against false designation
of origin, so basically
the false designation
that would cause confusion
over origins, sponsorship,
or association of the good.
And the second thing is about
misrepresentation of the nature,
characteristics, qualities,
or geographical origin
of the goods.
So from a standpoint
of more rights,
the provision would prevent
you from providing your name
to some other works that's
not being created by you
or misrepresenting the
nature of the work.
So, a good example would
be the Gilliam case,
which in the classroom
you should refer
to as the Monty Python case,
where ABC took out 24 minutes
of 90 minutes programming
and showed it and claimed
that it's basically
by Monty Python,
so when Monty Python saw
that, it was appalled
by the disjointive format of the
programming that has been shown
on TV and tried to pursue and
action based on both copyright,
as well as, Section 43(a).
And so with respect to 43(a)
claim, that's basically
when you're showing the older
version without authorization
and claiming that it is ours,
than you're not really
presenting a product,
but misrepresenting
what they have.
And so that's a very good
example, but I think a lot
of the audience members
are very concerned
about the Supreme
Court case of Dastar.
In that case, the
issue is basically
about the TV series that's
been put together by FOX
and that has gone
out of copyright
and that's not been renewed
and when they saw put together
videos have a condensed version
they slapped the opening
credits, they changed the,
I think, the toward the
end with the recapitulation
and re-order it a
little bit and show it
in a more condensed version but
just include Dastar right there
without mentioning FOX.
So the, when case
went all the way
to the Supreme Court the issue
is whether they would be able
to pursue a Section 43(a) claim
based on misrepresentation,
and as Eric mentioned early
on, what it could look
at is basically the origin
of the good is the origin
of the video that which
is the manufacturer
of the physical goods and
that's why they're not focusing
on the origin of the
footage or origin
of the intellectual material
that has been captured
within the videotape.
And I think there are
two different readings,
and I think a lot
of the commentators,
a lot of the lawyers
have been debating
as to how broad you're
going to read this,
or how narrow you're
going to read it.
I think the broad
reading is that we focus
on the physical goods
and you will not be able
to claim any false
designation of origin based
on the content inside
the physical good, right.
So that would be a very broad
reading of the Dastar case,
but I'm more in line
with the camp
that has a more narrow reading
and a more narrow reading is
that if you look
at the case it's
about public domain
material that's already gone
into the public that's
not protected anymore
and if you want to go even
deeper you can see that a lot
of the footage is actually
from the allied forces
and so it's not even
from FOX, right.
So you have a lot of
different ingredients
that will actually lead
the court to say that,
"Well if you look at the
origin, than, there is no need
to actually credit
faults especially
when it has gone in
a public domain."
So that's one way to look at it.
And then I also know a number
of commentators have actually
separated non-attribution
from misattribution.
So non-attribution is basically
you did not include the name
to the footage, in the case,
footage that's already gone
in a public domain
and misattribution
is basically similar
to the Gilliam case were you
actually put somebody else's
name or you alter the state of
the footage and then you claim
that it's the original.
And in the Dastar case
I think it goes closer
to non-attribution but not
so much to misattribution,
so had the Gilliam case been put
forward before the Dastar court,
I guess the outcome may
be somewhat different
because of an altered state, but
I think the concern for a lot
of commentators is that after
the Dastar case there are also a
lot of lower courts
that are trying
to apply the very broad
reading of Dastar and showing
that there would be very limited
protection under Section 43(a)
in terms of the attribution
interest
within the intellectual work and
I think that has caused concern
for a lot of those
people who want
to have stronger moral
rights protection.
>> Aurelia Schultz: Thank you.
Keeping on the attribution
track there,
earlier in the first panel
there was mention of some
of the newer WIPO Treaties
and of course those
include protection
for Rights Management
Information or RMI.
So Mickey could you talk to
us a bit about RMI protection
as a way for protecting
moral rights?
>> Mickey Osterreicher: Sure.
So with my press
background for those of you
who are not connected
to the Internet,
right across the
street I'll let you know
that the Supreme
Court denied cert
in the Google case,
the book case.
So I think that's something
people will be talking
about today in our area, but
that breaking news aside,
earlier somebody talked
about how it really wouldn't
make any sense to publish a book
without somebody's name on it.
And yet with hundreds
of millions
of images being uploaded almost
daily we are seeing all those
images for the most part
without somebody's name on it,
and the Right Management
Information is critical
to at least visual
journalists and visual creators
in terms of doing that.
So attribution, attribution
information under moral rights;
the problem under moral
rights they have is
that it's very narrow in terms
of it's got to be
for exhibition.
It has to be numbered
no more than 200 works,
more than 200 copies made
and for the most part,
those visual images in terms
of photography will not fall
under those protections,
so what else can we do?
And then we have a number of,
now we get in to all the
acronyms, and again, standards.
For Rights Management
Information,
there's a Copyright
Management Information,
CMI and that's codified under
Section 1202 of the DMCA,
and we can talk about that.
I'm not sure if you want
to talk about that now
or when you go to
the next question.
Then, you know, then we have
IPTC and EXIF and then PLUS
and we don't really just yet
have a standardization in terms
of how we are going to allow the
people that create visual works
to have that attribution.
Whether it's information
just about them and even
when there's information there
that will help people identify
who it is that created that work
often times that information
that is referred to often as
metadata is stripped out of
that of the visual works
and we have pretty much
almost instant orphan works
if you will, for an image
that could have been created
only moments ago when it goes
up on the Internet and
is seen around the world.
Somebody may not know who it is
and often times these images are
being used without permission
or credit or compensation, and
that really is a huge problem.
You were talking about
performing artists in terms
of visual artists trying to have
and earn a living doing what
they do in this brave new world
of so many millions of
images being out there,
that's a dilemma that we
are truly-truly faced with.
So, you know, under DMCA
they're certainly a number
of really better protections
as far as we're concerned;
the real question is going
to be then enforcement
and that's seems to be a big
challenge for everybody in terms
of what they're dealing
with, setting the standards
and then enforcing them.
So, I think maybe as we get
into some more questions
I'll get into more specifics.
>> Aurelia Schultz:
Okay, thank you.
And you mentioned a little
bit there how dealing
with photographers is different
than other types of visual arts
and we've talked a
little bit about VARA
in the first panel as well.
Professor Yu, was there anything
you would like to add on VARA
that you feel we haven't covered
in any either of
the panels so far?
>> Peter K. Yu: So, we
touch on VARA a little bit.
I think this is actually a topic
where most people
are quite familiar.
So the Visual Artists
Rights Act which was adopted
in 1990 covered three
different types of rights.
One is the attribution right,
the second one is
the integrity right,
and then the third one
is basically the right
against destruction of
works of recognized stature.
And so when you look
at the comparison,
I think Daniel Gervais talk
about VARA in the context
of the Berne Convention,
you can see
that we actually offer more
protection in terms of the right
of -- against destruction of
works of recognized statute
and I think that type of right,
you can discribe that as closer
to right of destruction
or right of integrity,
but you can also make a
good comparison to a lot
of our state preservation laws.
So in California, in New
York, in a lot of places.
And so that's more like a hybrid
if I have to describe that,
our public court as more rights
with U.S. characteristics.
And with respect to the Berne
Convention I think the main
concern for a lot of people is
basically we are narrowing the
scope of the protection, so
the protection is only limited
to a very limited
category of works
so that would be paintings,
sculpture, prints and drawings.
And so even within
those categories,
they would have more conditions
attached to what you have,
so a good example
would be photographs.
As we just heard earlier on, we
will have limits to the number
of copies, so a single copy or
200 or fewer copies and then
after that you also have
to have at least signed
or consecutively numbered
by the author and then
at the very end you also have
the purpose, it has to be
for exhibition purposes only.
And so there is actually
case law talking
about what would actually cover
within that particular phrase,
so you can see that it has been
very narrow and I think in terms
of protection, that's also
more narrow than what we have
in the Berne Convention.
In the Berne Convention
is usually life
of the author plus 50
years as the standard,
and in the U.S. we have life
of 70, but when you look
at the Visual Artists Rights
Act, it's basically life
of the author and that's
basically it stop right there
and so it's not really
implausible to the duration
of copyright, but it's
actually shorter than that.
And so I think with respect to
the Visual Artists Rights Act,
what's interesting is that we
try to come up with something
that is quite unique for us
and that's also acceptable
at that time, but at the same
time, it doesn't fit very well
in terms of both the Berne
Convention, as well as,
the scope of protection we
get in both the attribution,
as well as, right of integrity.
>> Aurelia Schultz: Thank you.
At the end of the last
panel, Miss Devorah mentioned
that in her opinion most
of this should be covered
by contract law.
Allan could you tell
us briefly a little bit
about how contract law can play
into this and then we'll turn
to Mike and hear about some
specific types of contracts.
>> Allan Alder: Yeah, the notion
of contract law was also one
of the reasons why
publishers generally objected
to the imposition of a
layer of moral rights on top
of the existing economic rights
and property rights framework
of U.S. copyright law.
In part because they felt
that contracts gave the parties
both great degree of flexibility
in terms of how to develop and
conduct their own relationship
with respect to the publication
of work, but at the same time,
it addition to that flexibility,
once a contract was in place
and had been fully negotiated,
it also added a great deal
of certainty and
predictability about the way
in which the relationship
would continue and the work
at the center of that
relationship would be
dealt with.
There is, of course,
as has been said,
there's not attribution right in
U.S. copyright law specifically
but that's an issue
that is typically dealt
with under contract.
Many works in the United
States are published either
pseudonymously or anonymously
and that's generally dealt
with between the
author and the publisher
as a matter of contract.
And the courts, of course,
generally tend not to try
to read between the lines
of a contract unless it's
absolutely necessary to do so.
So it's the express language of
what's within the four corners
of the contract that ultimately
shape the relationship
of the publisher and
the author with respect
to a particular work and how
copyright law is implemented
with respect to that
specific work
in the context of
that relationship.
One of the curious things
that we see though is is
that sometimes I think
that there is a situation
where the notion of a contract
or at least the way licenses are
used today, can put the issue
of attribution and integrity
in opposition to each other.
I'll give you one example;
there is a pending rule-making
at the Department of Education
called the Open Licensing Rule
in which the Department
of Education is trying
to encourage the creation of
open education or resources
through its direct
competitive grant program.
And as a result,
what it wants to do
with the rule is
impose the obligation
on any grant recipient
that any copyrightable work
that they produce
with grant funds
from the Department would have
to be available publically
as open educational
resources basically subject
to the equivalent of a
Creative Commons attribution
only license.
The problem with that is that
because they essentially say
to the individual that if
you receive federal funds
to create a work, that work,
not only is going to be subject
to various kinds of adaptation
and repurposing and alteration
by other parties down the line,
but at each instance they say,
because they determine when
they developed Creative Commons
licenses that most people did at
least want to have attribution
as a requirement
of the transaction.
They require that at each stage
of that process attribution
to the original author be
made and what that means is
that you're going to have a
circumstance where as a result
of that kind of license
agreement, that as a result
of receiving federal funding
and the contract terms
for that funding, you're
going to have this situation
where an individual author
continues to be credited
as the author of a work after it
has been substantially altered,
repurposed, adapted in ways
that that author might
find absolutely appalling
and completely at odds
with their original purpose
in publishing that
particular work.
So contracts can
do a lot of things.
They provide flexibility.
They provide certainty.
They allow the parties basically
to decide their own fates
within a particular transaction.
Now we have heard
on occasion that one
of the reasons why moral rights
needs to cut into that kind
of flexibility and
freedom of contracting is
because frequently the
bargaining positions
of the parties, and in my field
it would be the bargaining
position between an author
and a publisher, are unequal.
Well, they can be unequal but in
two very different directions.
A very well-known author
with a very long track record
of success in publication
typically will have more
leverage than the publisher will
in determining the transactional
terms of the next publication
if that publisher wants
to become the publisher
of the author's next work.
Obviously the situation is
reversed when you're dealing
with an author, either a
first time author or an author
who has developed a
little public reputation
and little record of
success in publications
with previous authors
or previous publishers.
So, you find the situation
where contracting is something
that is more conducive
to the U.S. system.
It seems to be something that
in civic code countries has
to be cabined within the terms
of civil law and that was one
of the reasons why
publishers continued to feel
that a moral rights
regime with that kind
of European flavor would
basically be detrimental
to the way copyright had served
the interests of this country.
>> Aurelia Schultz: So Mike,
Allan mentioned Creative Commons
licenses and they're something
that has sometimes been
talked about by scholars
as potentially being
Americas' moral rights.
Could you share some of your
thoughts on that and then also
on the role of extralegal
norms in the area?
>> Michael Wolfe: Absolutely.
So Creative Commons licenses,
which I'm sure many or all
of you are familiar
with are a suite
of public licenses designed to
allow the widespread sharing,
in some cases reusing and
remix, of creative work.
And as Allan just recently
mentioned, one of the
or the essential condition
of Creative Commons license
in in fact an attribution
requirement.
So every license takes the form
of usually a hyphenated string
of two character abbreviations.
A CC BY would be the
CC attribution license
and that can be amended
by selecting from a menu
of options, any of a number
of different requirements.
The licensor can elect to not
to disallow derivative works
or to require that
further, that creators
of derivative works share
them under the terms
of the same license,
share a like license.
Or that require that any use
of the work be noncommercial
or down streaming is the
working on commercial.
And I would, just to back up,
and respond a little bit to one
of Allan's comments about open
education resources and the use
of a bare CC BY license
and its impact
on specifically the
right of integrity.
There, it is important to note
that if it is a CC license
that CC licenses also provide
some measure for a right
of disassociation and it does,
it would be a flip, a little bit
of a flip of a default but where
work is modified in such a way
that the author no longer feels
comfortable having their name
associated with the CC license
standard terms do require
that a downstream user remove
the name of the original author
where reasonably practicable
So these are an interesting
solution.
I wouldn't call them an
American solution entirely.
They are American in origin.
Creative Commons was
originated in the United States,
but it is a global licensing
scheme and it's designed
to be global and
portable to that
and the CC licenses
provide for more rights.
And in fact, while they, the,
all of the licenses
have a provision
that waive moral rights but
only to the extent necessary
to reasonably effectuate
the license and only
where actually waivable
in the jurisdiction.
There's an interesting
question of how and whether
in Attribution, BY, license
is equivalent to a moral right
of attribution overseas.
It seems to me that not only
is the attribution right an
effective tool for providing the
recognition that many authors
who use Creative Commons
licenses specifically are
seeking to garner
through their work,
that the CC licenses also tackle
some of the more fiddly aspects
of what it means to have
an attribution regime
in an online environment.
And this is a lot of what Mickey
was talking about with regards
to Right Management Information,
but merely having the name
of the author associated
with the work seems today
to be somewhat insufficient
for the purposes
of having the author
be properly credited.
And to that end, CC
is also a scheme,
a digital recognition scheme
where there's a cascading amount
of copyright management
information pointing both
to the author, any attribution
party specified by the author,
the copyright notice, the
terms of the license itself
which are available on
a stand-alone website
that is easily linked
to and findable.
A notice refers to the
disclaimer of warrantees
and a URI or a hyperlink
to the specified place
where the information
resides on the Internet.
And given how easily Rights
Management Information can be
stripped, it isn't
necessarily a complete solution
to the realities of
online attribution,
but it takes the problem
seriously and does
so in a way that's readily
accessible to any user
of the Creative Commons suite.
And there's also the
interesting effect of having,
of encouraging attribution
beyond the scope of copyrights.
So even though the Creative
Commons licenses are not,
do not report to be,
broader than copyright,
they allow for the
varous exception
and any other any other
exception or limitation
that the Copyright Act provides.
They still nonetheless,
encourage by taking advantage
of most individuals
risk eversion compliance
with their terms.
So, in the instance
of over compliance,
CC licenses in some way suggest
and recommend attribution even
where perhaps not absolutely
required by copyright law
or by the license itself.
Moving on, I'm actually
going to segue directly
into a topic that's not
entirely directly related,
and that's how extralegal
norms stand in place
of moral rights in
the United States.
So, there is, as the
panel has discussed,
a significant patchwork of
rights that to some extent,
if not completely,
provides something akin
to moral rights protection
to American authors
and authors in the
United States.
But the reality on the ground
is substantially lighter,
or just based off norms and
practices within communities
and particularly around
the norms of plagiarism
which is what I'm going
to focus on today.
Plagiarism which comes from,
I think the Latin root is
from kidnapped or kidnapper,
is an extralegal norm
independently defined
in various communities of
practice that cautions against
and provides often extralegal
remedies for against the uses
of works that are in some way
fraudulent or unauthorized.
And generally in the sense
of not including attribution
information that we take
to be an essential part of their
right, there isn't an identity
with infringement here.
And if you think of the
way I've been trying
to consider the topic is
viewing the possible areas
of wrong doing as
almost as a Venn diagram
where infringement attribute,
a right of attribution
and plagiarism are all
mutually overlapping
and characterizing
the problem that way,
there is a significant portion
of the attribution right
that might cover what today in
the United States as plagiarism
or what might not be
plagiarism at all,
but is nonetheless not
copyright infringement either.
So, plagiarism, I've
sidetracked myself a little bit,
and there are one of the virtues
of having an extralegal norm
as opposed to a formal
statutory right,
although I won't
draw any conclusions
as to whether this
affects the propriety
of having the statutory right,
is that within various
communities
of practice there can be and, in
fact, are different approaches
to the question of plagiarism.
In the case of literary works,
academia has very strong
norms about plagiarism.
Not all of which are
necessarily entirely consistent
with what we might think
of attribution for work.
If a research assistant provides
significant contributions
to a paper, the fact that
their name does not appear
on the text will not generally
be considered plagiarism
or in violation of the norms
of plagiarism despite the
existence of the contributions.
Meanwhile for student
works, there are the taking
of unattributed sources
is a serious infraction
that can result in
expulsion or any number
of academic disciplinary
measures happening
within the case of a school.
Whereas in creative writing,
attribution while
considered a requirement,
and there is a very strong norm
of plagiarism might not
be take the same way
as a formal academic approach to
credit, so rather than footnotes
or citations, you
might have something
like Jonathan Lethem's
excellent essay, "The Ecstasy
of Influence" which is
subtitled "a plagiarism"
and composed entirely of
plagiarized sentences.
All of the sources of which
are credited in a sense
by the being listed at the
end, but not in line or by,
and not in quotation marks
with ellipses and the way
that lawyers are very
familiar with in way
that would meet the norms
of academic scholarship.
And in film, even in the Dastar
case, that was acknowledged
by Justice Scalia to be
an effect of plagiarism
and for FOX's purported
remedy essentially
to be an action for plagiarism.
But it only, plagiarism only
extends in many cases as far
as norms allow and today we have
contracts will usually negate
some of what we would consider
plagiarism or violation
of attribution right
in the sense
of a ghost writing
contract allowing
for only the reported
author's name
and the not the ghost
writer's name
and I've completely lost my
train of thought so I'm going
to wind it down there.
>> Aurelia Schultz: Thank you.
Thank you gentlemen.
I know there's a
lot more to cover.
We have just a few minutes left
for questions from the audience.
Where are my mic runners?
>> Unidentified Male
Speaker: Great, thank you.
I want to take exception
to a comment
that my friend Allan Alder made.
I don't always disagree
with Allan, but Allan stated
and a good thing
I'm paraphrasing,
"Contracts give flexibility
and certainty
as to how work would
be dealt with."
Well, in my experience in
my previous life at ASMP,
it's a trade association,
over the years the one thing
that we could be certain
regarding most textbook
publishing licenses
and contracts was
that they were being exceeded.
There was no certainty
that the terms
of the contract was
being upheld.
So, and I agree with you, the
leverage issue I'm not sure
that I think that tilts still
more in favor of the publisher
than the number, I guess,
authors that have significant
leverage over a publisher.
I think it's significantly less
than the number that don't,
but as far as contracts
were concerned,
I don't think they gave
any particular certainty
as to what was happening
with the future of a work.
>> Allan Alder: Well I guess,
let me try to clarify that Jim
because what I meant and I
think you've referend this,
is that the terms of the
contract creates certainty.
Now, whether or not
the terms are complied
with is another question and the
fact that you are able to point
out in a given situation that
the facts of implementation
of that contract don't match the
terms indicates that there is
at least the possibility and
the intention of certainty,
it simply isn't followed
through in terms of performance.
So I think that you
still have the notion
that contracts are useful
for providing certainly the
aspiration towards certainty
and predictability, but
you're still dealing
with the question
ultimately of whether
or not the performance will be
faithful to that aspiration.
>> Unidenfied Male Speaker:
Then we still we almost agree.
>> Aurelia Schultz: Daniel.
>> Daniel Gervais: It's also
for Allan and also on contracts.
So you underscore the
almost sanctity of contract,
why it's so important, yet the
United States has something
that authors in other countries
envy which is the termination
of transfers which
seems to be a little bit
of government interference in
the contract and I understand
that some of the work around,
especially that some lawyers
in Nashville have
tried for termination
of transfers have not
all been tested in court,
but it's a pretty
strong unwaivable
on transferable right, is
that unemployment-American?
>> Allan Alder: I think
as you probably would agree
Daniel that's the exception
by far rather than proving
the general rule of the way
in which freedom of contract
is generally allowed to operate
within the copyright
system and more importantly,
drives the copyright
system increasingly
because of the increasingly
broad role that licensing
of the use of works plays.
We're seeing within the context
of the current copyright review
this, you know, battle playout
between those who are
advocating the importance
of continued certainty in
definition with respect
to ownership of rights
with respect
to a particular work whereas
we're also seeing society
that is increasingly
content simply to have access
to use the work is not really
interested in ownership
because of the other attributes
that ownership usually has
which requires maintenance,
storage, care,
things of that nature,
upgrades, whatever.
So I think that I wouldn't point
to the exceptional circumstances
as generally initiating the rule
which I think continues to be
that contract plays a
very important role.
I mean, one point I would I
would also want to make here is
that when we talk about
the integrity with respect
to the issue of its match on the
U.S. copyright law with respect
to the right to control the
production of derivative works,
but there's always
going to be the question
of what actually is derivative.
At the far end of the spectrum,
I suppose it's possible
that using the common
understanding of the word
"derivative", work can
steal completely the ideas
of a prior author's work but
not of course be actionable
as copyright infringement,
because it doesn't take
the original expression.
So, you have to have a notion
of these legal concepts
that is susceptible
to clear definition.
It's always going to be
the case that we're going
to have ligation, because
as June mentioned we are a
particularly litigious society
and we'll always be trying
to game the fringes and
the edges of these rights.
But today for example, we're
seeing discussion of whether
or not remixes and matchups are
vitiating a derivative right.
If that's true, I don't know
that anybody has related the
question of remixes and matchups
to moral rights at this point,
but it certainly seems to be
that that's another
avenue to be explored.
>> Duncan Crabtree-Ireland:
Actually if before you go
onto the next question
just say --
I think one of the talks we
didn't discuss, but is thinking
about the importance
of contracts
with collaborative works
and how the, you know,
a lot of challenges would exist
in the absence of the prevalence
of contracts for
collaborative works
like in the audiovisual area
because how you would coordinate
and harmonize different
participants,
different moral rights
and other rights
without contract would be
quite a complicated scenario.
>> Allan Alder: In fact, Eric's
history of in the late 1980s
at the time of Berne
implementation
and immediately thereafter
left out the fact
that in the hearings that
were held about moral rights,
the other main issue being
discussed was the impact
of moral rights on the work for
hire doctrine and particularly
because the Supreme Court had
just decided the Reid case,
and at the point there was a
real question as to whether
or not it was possible
to create a situation
in statutory copyright law that
would accommodate that notion
as the Europeans have it,
but still be consistent
with the way the Supreme
Court interpreted the work
for hire doctrine which
depended greatly upon the way
in which a written contract
essentially defined the
relationships of the party.
>>Aurelia Schultz:
Thank you gentlemen.
I'm afraid that's all the
time we have for this session.
We have a short break
until 11:20
and then we'll have our
keynote, and for those
who are standing there
is room up in the front
and in the middle so
please do feel free
to fill in during the break.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.